hello I'm Ben kickert I'm with starting
up good and my presentation is on
structuring diverse data sources for
machine learning and analysis
hello how is everybody today I I have
the envious position of being in the
after lunch slot so I will do my best to
keep you entertained and you know
hopefully the the Z's won't be tempted
to come after you my name is Ben kickert
and I work with a diverse and and loose
coalition of people who are interested
in making the world a better place we
have a couple projects that we work on
called SDG counting as well as starting
up good where we take Steven Wolfram's
idea of computational X and for us the X
is about things like impact investing
and the sustainable development goals so
I was here last year when I was very new
to the Wolfram world didn't have as much
experience as I do now and was kind of
fumbling my way through how can we use
the Wolfram stack to explore the
sustainable development goals and in
case you're not familiar the sustainable
development goals are essentially the
the business plan for the world on how
we can make the world a better place
so we look at 17 goals and 163 targets
and 240 something indicators and with
that we see vast amounts of data coming
in you look at different UN agencies who
contribute you look at individual
businesses that contribute all of these
people who are coming together and
saying we want to be a part of this much
bigger movement known as sustainable
development and one of the things we run
into when we talk about the sustainable
development goals is in fact we have too
much information we have some great
stuff coming from the World Health
Organization and we have some great
stuff coming from UNESCO and we have
some great stuff coming from individual
countries but how do we make sure that
all of these things are talking to each
other and so that's what we want to look
at today we want to look at how we can
take these diverse data sources from not
only diverse in structure but also
diverse in the format that you're going
to receive them and how can we take that
and move it through the structuring
process and the cleaning process and get
it to the point that we can actually do
machine learning on it or that we can
create other and
coming from the the Wolfram stack that
we can actually use all of these things
so I'll tell you right from the
beginning this is a survey course we're
gonna touch on quite a bit of diverse
information none of this is going to be
in-depth when we get to some of the
machine learning there are people in
this room that can do it a whole lot
better than me so I will leave that to
them to do so just to start the
objective of this presentation is to
talk about how we can take specifically
in the area of health very diverse data
sources and be able to predict a life
expectancy of a country it's a slightly
arbitrary conclusion that we're coming
to but for us it kind of illustrates how
we can take information not only put it
together
but come to a meaningful conclusion so
in this case what we're gonna look at is
we're gonna look at Wolfram entities
specifically country data we're gonna
look at a sequel light database that's
based on the CIA Factbook we're gonna
look at CA CSV data that came from the
big UN SDG database we're gonna look at
api's and JSON from the w-h-o and their
global health observations and then
we're gonna do some web scraping to pull
in some information from a secondary
site that gives its own scores on how
countries are doing so if your goal is
to take diverse data sources and you
want them to get them you want to get
them together there's two things that
you need to do the first is that you
need to choose in advance what your
final format is going to be in this
example we're moving everything to data
set but we've done work where we've
moved everything to relational entities
stores you have to make that first
decision second you need to identify one
or more primary keys that you can use to
connect one set of data to the next so
we're going to start with Wolfram
entities and I just want to give a shout
out not because I'm paid or anything but
I do want to say that one of the powers
of the Wolfram stack is actually built
in the curated data that's part of
Mathematica and the Wolfram language and
so instead of having to bring in your
sources just in your regular code or you
natural language inputs you have access
to over 300 data types that you can
bring in to your calculations when we
look at country data alone we have 750
properties that we can calculate on and
when you you continue to molecules if
you're a chemist or if you want to look
at other health data if if you're in
that profession and so when we look at
Wolfram entities this is a great
starting spot because we can choose from
these 750 entities which ones were
actually interested in building our
final data set from so if you you just
do a quick search of country properties
you see that you have everything from
seasonal bank borrowing from feds plus
adjustment not really relevant to me if
you work in finance that's something
that you have at your fingertips so for
us I actually went through that entire
list of 750 properties and said which of
these are helpful if we're trying to
make a determination about the health of
a country the overall health of a
country so we chose country code and UN
code because they can serve as our
primary keys we looked at the name for
easy reference the Gini index is a
measure of disparity within a country
basically what's the difference between
the richest and the poorest infant
mortality HIV GDP population and life
expectancy now one of the things I found
and I'm sure it's just a bugger could
even be on my system is that when I went
to pull information on per capita GDP
which could be huge if we're trying to
figure out life expectancy I went to
pull it in and Wolfram said that it
wasn't there and at first I got you know
I'll have to change my example but the
fact is is that when Wolfram when
Mathematica 12 came out they gave us the
ability to do extended entity classes
which allows you to take different
calculations put them all together and
then spit out a new entity property and
so what ended up originally being a bug
at least in my presentation I was able
to turn it into a new example about how
we can use data so once you have the
entity store and last year we look quite
a bit away you can do with entity data
I just wanted to pull it all out and
create a data set
with it if you look at it Wolfram
decides to format it this way which
isn't as nice as kind of the Excel table
that we're used to now one of the things
I found is the reason it does that is
because when you do a data set on
entities it's actually making the entity
property itself the key so if you look
at the keys there you see that instead
of just straight text which we're used
to it's actually a function itself and
so we have to to clean that up a bit
so we simply write some code clean that
up now we've got a better-looking data
set from there we want to take care of
the issue of quantity magnitude it's
great when we're dealing with
information all within Wolfram but when
you start bringing in different sources
we don't want all the units there so we
simply take the quantity magnitude and
from there that's the base that we build
the rest of our our data onto the next
thing I looked at is very much related
to entity stores and that's using the
relational database functionality that
also came out in version 12 here you
have the ability to take a relational
database like sequel Lite and treat it
like it's its own entity store great
presentations last year and I'm sure
this year on that so I'm not going to
get too in-depth about the processes for
it but in this case I've downloaded a
sequel database of the CIA Factbook
Steven actually showed this yesterday
all you have to do is once you name it a
relational database you pull it in as an
entity store you register it you can
pull into the properties just like you
would a regular entity set we have the
same issue with the way that it's
displayed and then the need to clean so
in this case we're taking the country
code it was lower case we want to make
sure our primary keys match so we turn
it all uppercase and then we take care
of a little of a few other naming issues
to make sure that we're consistent so at
this point now this is the simplest
level we've taken a independent sequel
like database and an entity an entity
store from Wolfram pulled out the
information we wanted and said hey let's
put it together and so now we have quite
a bit of information
that we can add that wasn't included in
the 750 into the properties that we had
initially if you're familiar with sequel
you get into the issues of inner join
outer join left join right join in this
case we chose outer join because we're
actually adding some information that we
didn't originally have so you can see
like the country code a n is Andorra
that's not listed in Wolfram's data
repository but for us we can still pull
in the information that we need okay
next and this is what I'm sure anybody
who's worked with data in in Mathematica
before is familiar with this this is
kind of the simplest way to deal with
data we're just going to take a csv file
import it into Mathematica as I said
this comes from the SDG database itself
you get the raw data when I first
started I thought that semantic import
was the coolest thing because I didn't
know how to create a data set on my own
so a very simple way that you can take
that CSV make it a data set but we do
have some issues with that sometimes it
uses an interpreter in a place you don't
want an interpreter sometimes it takes a
string and turns it into into integers
sometimes it takes integers and turns
them into strings and so for us we're
just gonna have a simple line of code to
turn it into our own data set and keep
everything as uniform as we can from
there one of the things we had was we
had some date ranges which were imported
as strings so you had 2015 through 2017
so we did a string split took only the
last date so that now we can use that in
a consistent way next we're looking at a
query essentially this is the the pivot
table of Mathematica where we're saying
I'm interested in basically the the
indicator from the SDGs I'm interested
in the geographic area name and all I
want is the value and with that we can
turn that information into a centrally a
pivot table that gives us the values for
each of the indicators that that we have
one of the things we found in the SDG
database information was it it didn't
have country codes
so this is where Wolfram as a large
your product really helps us out because
we can actually use the interpreter
function to take the country names tell
it that we want it to be interpreted as
a country and then extract the country
code that we can then add back into our
data set so we're using Wolfram and
Mathematica to not only combine the data
but also to interpret on its own what
primary key we need to use we can add
that to the primary data set
next we're looking at API API calls and
JSON the World Health Organization has
an absolutely incredible database this
is definitely an issue where you have
too much information and so using simply
import and putting the raw JSON as the
type into it it will automatically bring
it in as an association thread which you
can make into a data set from there you
can go in from the metadata and pull out
you can see here all 3287 indicators
that the w-h-o tracks the World Health
Organization so if you want to know the
leaders of beer consumption for any
given region of the world
w-h-o actually has that as part of their
data set we're not going to use it
instead we're gonna look at more under
five mortality as an indicator that we
can expect where we can calculate life
expectancy we can bring in all of the
country names and then since we have
that information
working through the API we simply
request exactly what we want it comes
back and says here are your values for
Afghanistan the under five mortality is
sixty four per 100,000 and on and on
clean that up a bit to give it the same
names and add it to our final data set
those last one is probably one that I'm
most interested in has anybody here you
use the the web session features that
also came out in Mathematica twelve is
that something that's that's new a
couple people all right so this is one
of those when I did it the first time
just watching it kind of got me excited
it's what we're gonna do is we're gonna
start a new web session so now
Mathematica is controlling my Chrome
browser and
case I wanted to open up the website
from SDG index dashboards so here's the
one for the United States and I look and
I see I'm interested in the SDG global
rank I'm interested in the index scores
and the regional averages and the GDP
but how do I bring that in through web
session so if you're in Chrome you click
inspect and then you inspect it again
it's gonna tell you what the div classes
with the division classes in this case
it's item total and so I can tell web
session to find every item total and
return the value for it it close that so
when I come in here and with a simple
line of code press ENTER and I now see
all those values scraped now if you
notice the website ended in the UN code
the USA we've already got that
information and so if I pull in all of
my country IDs from my earlier
information I can then run that code to
scrape every single country so I've run
it when I open up the web page you can
see it's cycling through every single
country that we have data for and every
time it loads the page it finds those
same divides and then it imports the
information that that we need we've used
this for numerous websites much much
easier than importing source and then
using string splits and cases to be able
to pull out and since it's using CSS
selector you can use the inspect and
actually there's a copy selector and
it'll tell you exactly how that that
item has been has been included so
that's going to come in and we're going
from you know this is this is
information that's in a dashboard not
easily accessible and in the span of
it'll probably yeah take less than a
minute there's the information that we
have we add our own keys and now we can
add that to our final database and clean
it up so at this point we've brought in
five different data sources we've
used api's we've used web scraping we've
used CSV input we've used Wolfram
entities and we've used sequel Lite
we've put all of them together into one
spot now what we do with it for us we
want to take all of those indicators and
see if there's a reliable correlation
between the data sources that we picked
and whether or not we can predict our
our life expectancy for a country so in
this case we're very quickly just
looking to see how many values we have
we've got some that are missing quite a
few we've got some that you know are
completely robust and have all of our
our data but what we want to do is give
ourselves the best chance possible in
this case we've got a lot of regions
we've got a lot of territories that
others aren't reporting on so we're just
doing a simple select and saying I want
to make sure you have life expectancy
because that's what we're trying to
predict and I want to make sure that you
have at least 10 values so let's create
a data set and in this case we've got
188 countries that works out perfect for
us because we know the UN tells us
there's about 190 to 195 that's a very
good starting spot we've done pretty
good on our data collection to use this
for AI first we define our AI data so
we're pulling in all of those indicators
that are not life expectancy putting
them together as a list threading it to
the final value of life expectancy we
start with some training data and so in
this case we're just taking a random
sample of 138 of those data points and
my computer's not liking me now are they
real and then we're separating out the
test data from that you can trust me
that's what happens there from there and
I mean I'm using very very very simple
machine learning coding we're just
running a predictor on training data
we're using the automatic method with a
performance goal of quality I've already
run it I won't run it again but there's
my comparison plot and so as I found
this in a lot of the work that we've
done when you have very low values like
this expression with something like like
life expectancy the cause of that is
probably not related to the very small
number of indicators that you brought on
but overall we can see that that we've
done we've done pretty good but one of
the issues we ran into in our work with
machine learning especially me as a
relative novice is that I wasn't
familiar with what all the methods did I
don't know the difference between naive
Bayes and random forests but what I do
feel like I can analyze a little bit is
what are the outputs what do those look
like and so we've written this code that
essentially does the training on a
variety of different methods so that you
can quickly look in one spot to see how
things work so here if we look at
decision tree the this is again we you
you run one code in the same data you
started with you can see our decision
tree tends to make very specific
predictions that range in
appropriateness standard deviation of
4.3 gradient boosted trees does a lot
better again trust me on that one
linear regression follows our predicted
line pretty well but we also notice that
it has a higher standard deviation than
when we were using nearest neighbor
random forest random forest is what was
predicted and that's what we actually
used and the awesome process is is not
nearly as good and so this allows us to
very quickly assess which method will
work one thing I've found again is as a
novice I'm sure there's a great reason
that somebody can explain to me often
you get into a situation where if you
run the predict the first time and then
you run it again five seconds later it
will actually give you a different
process so I wanted to be able to
isolate and say no this is this is what
I want so we can continue to run that
the last thing that we do quickly is
because the point of our process was to
bring these different data sources
together you can always bring in more
data than you need and then choose what
it is you wanted so in this case we can
look just at income data and see how
that affects our predictions or we can
look just at health measures to see how
that affects our data so then what I
think it's me most excited about all of
this is that this is not just useful for
machine learning every stage of the
process actually has a use when it comes
to data
Linux it's something you can use to fill
in missing values if you don't know what
the tuberculosis rate is maybe you can
estimate it by looking at the values you
do we've used this to classify things
where we have a social objective of a
certain activity and we can look at the
values pointing to it and decide what
social category should this be part of
and also you can use it as we've seen to
expand the entities and wolfram that you
have and so that's our our quick survey
run through Sprint of data structuring
and machine learning so on behalf of the
SDG counting and starting up good team
which is Benjy Maureen and canet thank
you all for your time
[Applause]